Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In the last few years, we have seen a bunch
of new AI-based techniques that were specialized
in generating new and novel images.
This is mainly done through learning-based
techniques, typically a Generative Adversarial
Network, a GAN in short, which is an architecture
where a generator neural network creates new
images, and passes it to a discriminator network,
which learns to distinguish real photos from
these fake, generated images.
These two networks learn and improve together,
so much so that many of these techniques have
become so realistic that we often can’t
tell they are synthetic images unless we look
really closely.
You see some examples here from BigGAN, a
previous technique that is based on this architecture.
So in these days, many of us are wondering,
is there life beyond GANs?
Can they be matched in terms of visual quality
by a different kind of a technique?
Well, have a look at this paper, because it
proposes a much simpler architecture that
is able to generate convincing, high-resolution
images quickly for a ton of different object
classes.
The results it is able to churn out is nothing
short of amazing.
Just look at that!
To be able to proceed to the key idea here,
we first have to talk about latent spaces.
You can think of a latent space as a compressed
representation that tries to capture the essence
of the dataset that we have at hand.
You can see a similar latent space method
in action here that captures the key features
that set different kinds of fonts apart and
presents these options on a 2D plane, and
here, you see our technique that builds a
latent space for modeling a wide range of
photorealistic material models.
And now, onto the promised key idea!
As you have guessed, this new technique uses
a latent space, which means that instead of
thinking in pixels, it thinks more in terms
of these features that commonly appear in
natural photos, which also makes the generation
of these images up to 30 times quicker, which
is super useful, especially in the case of
larger images.
While we are at that, it can rapidly generate
new images with the size of approximately
a thousand by thousand pixels.
Machine learning is a research field that
is enjoying a great deal of popularity these
days, which also means that so many papers
appear every day it’s getting really difficult
to keep track of all of them.
The complexity of the average technique is
also increasing rapidly over time, and what
I like most about this paper is that it shows
us that surprisingly simple ideas can still
lead to breakthroughs.
What a time to be alive!
Make sure to have a look at the paper in the
description as it also describes how this
method is able to generate more diverse images
than previous techniques and how we can measure
diversity at all because that is no trivial
matter.
This episode has been supported by Weights
& Biases.
Weights & Biases provides tools to track your
experiments in your deep learning projects.
It is like a shared logbook for your team,
and with this, you can compare your own experiment
results, put them next to what your colleagues
did and you can discuss your successes and
failures much easier.
It takes less than 5 minutes to set up and
is being used by OpenAI, Toyota Research,
Stanford and Berkeley.
In fact, it is so easy to add to your project,
the CEO himself, Lukas instrumented it for
you for this paper, and if you look here,
you can see how the output images and the
reconstruction error evolve over time and
you can even add your own visualizations.
It is a sight to behold, really, so make sure
to check it out in the video description,
and if you liked it, visit them through wandb.com/papers
or just use the link in the video description
and sign up for a free demo today.
Our thanks to Weights & Biases for helping
us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!